me explain it to you so women leave
women divorced men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women are so to a guy's
point of view he's going to commit to
this girl and what does he get he
doesn't get Purity anymore you know
these hoes you know he doesn't he
doesn't get youth anymore so he doesn't
get either of those things a lot of
times she already has a kid so so he's
not fulfilling his mating strategy on
top of that even if he does find a good
woman that maybe has the qualities he's
looking for she was going to want him to
marry her right and what does he get out
of that oh she can leave and take half
and take my kids and she's paid to take
my kids away from me she she gets more
money if she takes my children and so
from the men's point of view they're
just kind of like eff it because like
women aren't wives nowadays
and what do they get out of it but men
are logical they're logical people and
so they're thinking does the benefit
outweigh the cost and like